be unhelpful or helpful it's some random
bad guy
a fan of ours yeah we don't know who it
is go ahead unhelpful advice
with bobby klyla and kristen
hi guys i'm a guy in my 30s and i've
been with my wife since high school
almost 20 years now
we've never broken up been together the
entire time and i'm still incredibly
happy to be with her
um i want to stay with her forever
however
since we got together so young neither
of us had sex with anyone else
that didn't bother me until recently
when i started to get that nagging
feeling that i'm missing out
experiencing sex with multiple people in
my life
i casually brought the idea of a
threesome and she has expressed some
mild by curiosity
but she's rejected the idea and seems
content with the status quo my question
is
should i one ignore these feelings two
tell her with more
clearly i want to explore a threesome or
three hire a sex worker once
without her knowledge to see if i can
get it out of the system
basically she'll cheat on her three not
three
[Laughter]
my honest thing right is all right i
mean
you know what i'm gonna just say this
you know a lot of our helpful advice
we're being too helpful
and can i be the unhealthy guy they'll
be the helpful you'll be getting healthy
yeah
of you don't get angry will you not get
angry
go ahead i already heard your answer i
want to go more into detail
all right i'm saying that you know wait
this guy's really going to listen to you
so like
but i really kind of mean what i'm about
to say oh dear god but it's also
unhelpful
it's unhealthy don't do it don't i'm
telling the guy don't do
it but do it you know what i mean
just listen to my point of view okay i'm
listening to okay so whatever you say
applies to me
oh true you because as when you are in a
couple
you represent one another thank you so
whatever you tell him
to do i can also do the same thing
no because i'll tell you why because you
don't even know what i'm going to say it
does it applies to you
because we're monogamous we're
monogamous yeah we're going to save them
no but no we're not just going to say it
we have been unless you've i've never
exactly i've never cheated we've been
monogamous before we'll give your advice
i'm going to tell you
that okay okay justin but i don't know
if i would be monogamous
if you were my first one
okay but so what i'm saying is is that
the reason why
i'm okay to be monogamous is because
i've been there dog what's up you know
what i mean i've been knee-deep in it
dog my point is
i've had all kinds of experiences dog
right
so what i'm saying is that i know i'm
with the best one
because i've sampled you know what i
mean dog
you don't know also because you fall
you're in love with her that's
that's not because you're not just with
me because you've seen it all and i'm
just the last one in line i know but
that thought though
isn't in my head that nagging thought
like what if
this and that right i don't know what
that would be like
but isn't that but okay with him saying
that
yes the the whatever isn't that more of
a reflection on
on the current relationship status like
i think no matter how many people you've
slept with
you can always find they'll say the
grass is going to always be greener like
i
there's one more to see than whatever
but isn't it something about
the relationship that says
maybe something else is missing you know
what that's not about a sexual
relationship
maybe maybe or it's just like look if
i've been
if i'm 36 today and i've been with
someone since high school that means
we've been together two decades
i would hope that this is something that
i'm able to communicate
to someone that i've trusted for the
last 20 years and that i can say hey
these are my feelings
we've been together for so long she's
likely gonna say i've had similar
feelings
right but we're not gonna go ahead and
jump in front of every that situation
and say oh i'm gonna get a sex worker
it's gotta you gotta give your wife a
chance to sort of
be part of the decisions that you make
because i mean
they're in a monogamous relationship but
if you say you get a sex
i'm gonna get a [ __ ] second i changed
i changed i'm gonna what because what
kristen said until i changed
okay and this is kind of worse
why did you make it worse what i'm about
to say is kind of worse
okay maybe
right i believe and this is a theory
that i have that even somebody like
let's just
let's look at barack and michelle obama
uh-huh right sure
all right tread lightly i love him
huge fan michelle obama all right so
what i'm saying is
um even barack yeah right when
he's not with michelle 24 7 you're right
he might go do a lecture or you know i
mean he'll
do something go on tv or whatever you
might be right and i'm sure
without michelle being there there are
like women that adore him right you can
tell
right that women you know i mean they
they love what i'm already doing
no just let's go i'm annoyed with that
because it's as if michelle doesn't have
the same thing that surrounds her
right yeah and she does too and both
cases she's
hot in both in both cases right
i'm sure barack sees a beautiful
attractive woman and goes
what would that be like in their head we
are
right no look at that photo look at that
yeah
i just love them
i'm gonna say i love them as well i'm
just saying that you know
right some white girl right why are we
using barack and michelle obama yeah
we should be using like i don't know
gilbert do you have one way
i wanted to use the prime example okay
right i want to use
like you know how he's biting his bottom
lip i just right he's thinking
about the white chick that's in the
audience staring at him the teleprompter
point is
that i think that all even you
even you kristen yes even though that
you're married
right every once while you'll see a
woman that's very attractive
right and you'll think just let me
finish right and think to yourself
what would that be like all of us do
human nature is
yes that's what i'm telling this guy so
i'm just saying it doesn't matter
this is a positive thing but here's the
thing it's not that i i don't
necessarily think
oh what would it be like to sleep with
them yeah it's not like that it's it's a
it's a there's a there's a wall of
disconnect because when you are in a
relationship that is
fueling every aspect of who you are and
what you love
here we go it's not saying oh my god
you're so hot i want to sleep with you
yeah yeah
it's wow that's the difference between
guys and girls yeah it's it's
guys are just admiration of beauty are
guys different yes because you're
thinking with your penis you're leading
with this
yeah i lead with my foreskin so right
yeah you're thinking about sex
we're thinking about like a beautiful
human
right and yes oh my god you think you're
at some
ethereal [ __ ] i mean it's true you
guys don't have a single thought in your
brain like
anything can make you come if women if
we're not in the
correct mindset it's over i can never
get there
[Laughter]
get it live get in line cry me a river
wait wait so what was the advice there
is no advice [ __ ] that guy
good luck you would all say don't cheat
we would all say don't know
and i'm saying i'm saying careful i'm
gonna do it
all right don't cheat but suffer
suffer that's your options life is
suffering
and suffer through it let's give her a
round of applause christine
everybody thank you so much